this morning we remember the
longest-serving member of Congress in
American history former Michigan
Congressman John Dingell jr. died
yesterday after several health struggles
he was 92 years old tributes are pouring
in from across the political spectrum
former President Obama said Dingell led
the charge on so much of the progress we
take for granted today former President
George W Bush said he was a fine
gentleman who showed great respect for
our country and her people Dingell
passed many pieces of landmark
legislation in a nearly six decade long
career I see a waste of time a waste of
money and the behavior of a bunch of
people who look slow on the floor of the
house John Dingell was known for his
quick temper and pointed with the
Michigan congressman served under 11
presidents presidents come and
presidents go and John Dingell goes on
forever his career began in 1955 when he
took over the seat held by his father
John Dingell senior he played a key role
in the creation of Medicare and helped
lead the fight for civil rights let us
close the springs of racial poison in
2013 on Face the Nation he told Bob
Schieffer his vote for the 1964 civil
rights bill was one of his proudest
moments do you think that you could pass
the 1964 civil rights bill today I've
said the other day I wasn't sure we
could pass the 10 commandments in this
place in 2014 after 20 1572 days in
office Dingell announced his retirement
[Music]
retirement ignited his peppery sense of
humor he soon became a political hero on
Twitter with zingers that had many of
his followers questioning if it was
really the 92 year old typing them no
way a hundred year old in 2013 Dingell
reflected on his love of office in our
note to self series there will always be
work left to do and
never be enough hours in the day but
with God's help you'll try our people
still need public servants with every
good wish John a singular voice yeah I'm
now his wife Debbie Dingell who was
beloved in the House by both Republicans
and Democrats 'as as well we send our
condolences certainly do absolutely
funeral plans have not yet been
announced tingled leaves behind his wife
as Nora mentioned and four children and
the several grandchildren humor yeah